faire de l'histoire ce n'est pas
forcément retenir des dates parker
visiter des abbayes cisterciennes et
arpenter les rayons bibliothèque
il ya de ça oui mais pas que on peut
faire de l'histoire et mais cette
science sans passer nécessairement par
la science justement ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il existe des passerelles pour
apprendre et s'intéresser aux choses
youtube en est une et c'est d'ailleurs
sans doute pour ça que vous êtes là
devant votre écran à m'écouter
mais il en existe d'autres et la science
n'est science ne serait rien sans ses
passerelles
qu'est ce que j'entends par passerelle
des biens des moyens et des supports
pour communiquer une information assez
simples parfois créatives ou artistiques
vidéo voyage lecture réseaux sociaux
musique
si je vous dis que je me suis intéressé
à pompéi non pas par mes études en
archéologie mais grâce à pink floyd oui
oui le groupe de rock psychédélique 60
70 il ya peu de chances que vous fassiez
le lien à moins d'être un fan
inconditionnel du groupe ou bien
détrôner dans ces années-là donc en 1972
pink floyd privatise pompéi donne un
concert dans l'amphithéâtre de la cité
est ce son public
le groupe joue seul au milieu des ruines
à et avec un chien aussi la même année
le film sort au cinéma qui mixe plan du
live scène au studio et effets spéciaux
bien piqué c'est de cette façon que j'ai
redécouvert compagnie me suis attaché et
décidé de vous présenter ce lieu qu'ont
pays est une cité romaine antique située
en campanie à quelques kilomètres au sud
de naples on y va en train en longeant
la côte c'est très joli
elle est entièrement détruite et
enseveli par les cendres de l'éruption
du vésuve en 79 après jésus-christ un
bouchon de l'avs explose libérant un
immense nuage de plusieurs dizaines de
kilomètres de hauteur en forme de
champignon que spécialistes appellent le
panache volcanique
les cendres s'empilent sur une épaisseur
d'environ trois mètres
l'air est irrespirable et la région est
plongée dans une eau ni qui durera
plusieurs jours les villes de pompéi et
d'herculanum et de stabilo rayés de la
carte et on estime qu'un dixième de la
population de la région a péri durant
l'éruption
voilà pour les présentations très
générale que vous devez sans doute
connaître en partie à force de lier le
nom de la cité de pompéi à la
catastrophe
on en vient presque à oublier son
histoire son organisation son rôle
commercial et ses habitants
on l'enfermé dans une catégorie macabre
mais pompéi n'est pas une nécropole
alors c'est quoi mon pays avant le drame
eh bien ça va peut-être vous étonner
mais pompéi peu avant sa destruction est
une ville en chantier les dernières
découvertes archéologiques montrent que
la ville a subi plusieurs séismes avant
79 qui ont détruit une partie des
habitations
il faut donc imaginer que les habitants
de pompéi vivait avant l'éruption au
milieu des ruines et des bâtiments en
reconstruction à la suite de ces
tremblements de terre qui ont lieu 16 ou
17 ans à voyant ce glissement de la
ville on a préféré réutiliser les
matériaux des constructions détruites
on le voit particulièrement dans les
tavernes où les marbres des comptoirs
sont des réemploi des matériaux des
anciens bâtiments plutôt que de
reconstruire toutes les maisons et
villas touchés par les séismes
on a préféré dans l'urgence en raser une
partie pour aménager des espaces verts
et des jardins privés on comprend qu'au
moment de l'éruption pompéï est dans une
situation assez exceptionnelle en pleine
reconstruction marquée par des séismes à
répétition on s'éloigne donc peu à peu
de la vision romantique souvent donné
d'une ville riche et prospère conserver
intact par les cendres
c'est une erreur de la considérer comme
un exemple parfait de la cité antique
pompéi n'était pas une cité aussi
importante qu'on le dit en tout cas
moins que naples par exemple c'est plus
la région la campanie tout entière qui
est riche et célèbre
les terres sont fertiles ce qui en fait
le premier grenier à blé de l'italie et
lui donne une place majeure dans le
commerce international pompéi est une
ville modeste qui s'insère dans ce
système là en exportant notamment sa
production de vin pourtant on connaît
surtout pompéi pour ses fresques que ces
mosaïques ces objets en bronze et en
argent ses sculptures ses fontaines bref
les oeuvres d'art qui témoigne de la
richesse de leurs propriétaires la ville
accueille en fait à cette époque une
élite qui possèdent de grands domaines
agricoles
mais la plupart d'entre eux ne résident
pas à l'année à pompéi il exploite le
sol en faisant travailler des esclaves
et des fermiers qu'ils rémunèrent mon
pays c'est un peu le saint-trop' de
l'antiquité les riches y viennent en
villégiature se faisant construire de
somptueuses appartement attenant à leur
ferme et ceux qui vivent et travaillent
réellement à l'année sont bien moins
lotis
même si on a retrouvé une quantité
incroyable d'objets durant les fouilles
il faut bien avoir à l'esprit que pompéi
a subi un pillage considérable durant
des siècles en particulier les lieux
publics comme le forum
on a donc beaucoup de mal à restituer de
manière fiable ce qui était la cité au
premier siècle de notre ère
on sait que le site a été fréquenté
jusqu'au 4e siècle
et puis il est tombé dans l'oubli une
grande partie des vestiges ne faisant
pratiquement plus surface ce n'est que
vers 1600 que la cité antique et
découvertes
mais elle ne sera identifié qu en 1748
le dégagement du site commence de façon
assez anarchique et peu scrupuleuse des
très vite les squelettes exhumés des
victimes sont l'attraction du site
on n'hésite pas à mettre en scène des
fouilles où on découvre ces squelettes
lors de la venue de personnalités
célèbres
le tournant scientifique s'opère grâce à
giuseppe fiorelli qui prend la direction
des fouilles de pompéi et d'herculanum
dès 1860 pour la première fois une
équipe scientifique est déployée et
fiorelli se fait connaître en mettant au
point une méthode pour mouler les corps
des victimes
cette technique consiste à verser du
plâtre dans les espaces creux des
couches de cendres espace auparavant
occupé par des corps humains ou animaux
pompéi et les cités voisines représente
une étape clé dans l'histoire de
l'archéologie celle d'une première
approche scientifique avec les prémices
de la stratigraphie c'est-à-dire l'étude
des couches sédimentaires un bon exemple
est celui des fouilles des maisons
auparavant les dégager de manière
anarchique en commençant par les côtés
jusqu'à l'arrivée de fiorelli ou ont
compris qu'il fallait toujours commencer
par le haut puis descendre couche par
couche
c'est le principe numéro 1 de
l'archéologie puisque plus vous
descendez plus est ancien il faut bien
comprendre qu'avant qu'on pays
l'archéologie concentre essentiellement
des collectionneurs au xviiie siècle les
ruines antiques sont partis du paysage
men intéresse essentiellement que des
artistes comme piranèse l'archéologie
n'est de la découverte ou plutôt de la
re découverte de pompéi ce site
archéologique constitue au fil des
années un laboratoire où on élabore des
techniques de fouilles mais aussi des
moyens de conservation et de
restauration
s'étendant sur environ 65 hectares on
estime que 3 5e de sa superficie totale
ont été dégagés pompéi est en réalité le
plus grand musée du monde
si la cité a disparu en 79 sa mise au
jour et son ouverture au public depuis
le xviiie siècle signe sa seconde mort
les vestiges et en particulier les
fresques murales sont endommagés à
mesure que les touristes affluent sur le
site
ce processus de dégradation qui couvrent
d'un étrange voile blanc les peintures
des villas autrefois éclatante est
certes progressif mais inévitable les
archéologues ont donc décidé de ne pas
fouiller le reste de la cité et ce pour
deux raisons
éviter la dégradation des ruines qui
reste pour l'instant protégé par la
couche de cendre et laissé des vestiges
aux archéologues du futur
si vous visitez un jour pompéi ou
herculanum qui est d'ailleurs bien mieux
conservée sachez qu'il ne s'agit pas de
l'état antique de ces villes
après les fouilles et c'est normal les
sites ont été aménagés adapté au
tourisme de masse qui les caractérise
aujourd'hui de nombreux édifices ont été
reconstruits par exemple après les
bombardements allemands de 1943
on a solidifié arranger les murs avec
des matériaux modernes on a ajouté des
toitures pour protéger les décorations
on a renommé des rues et des maisons
pour faciliter la circulation etc etc
tout ça est certes essentielle à la
conservation du site mais ça témoigne
aussi d'une démarche
une façon d'envisager l'histoire et de
valoriser le patrimoine une démarche
qu'on pourrait résumer ainsi faire
visiter montrer au plus grand nombre au
prix d'une altération du site d'une
modification de son état original
si certains s'en est mort au nom de
l'exactitude historique ce que je peux
comprendre
je pense que permettre au plus grand
nombre de visites et ses ruines est l'un
des seuls moyens de transmettre une
réelle connaissance à leur sujet
la connaissance a besoin de l'émotion
qui est attaché au lieu et il faut pour
la ressentir s'y rendre physiquement
cette démarche est en définitive une
métaphore de la vulgarisation adaptons
de messages scientifiques pour mieux le
transmettre
mais c'est aussi ce qui m'avait vraiment
séduite dans le live de pink floyd la
façon de se réapproprier un lieu
l'amphithéâtre antique en respectant son
rôle celui d'accueillir un spectacle
mais cette fois avec des instruments
électriques par le som faire de nouveau
vibrer les murs de la cité mon travail
depuis plus d'un an c'est justement la
vulgarisation présenter la réalité
scientifique le plus simplement possible
en m'efforçant de ne pas tomber dans les
pièges audiovisuel du reportage avec une
musique de film à suspense insistant sur
le caractère secret caché des
civilisations disparues
les sujets archéologiques sont très
souvent traités sous le prisme de la
catastrophe
pompéi en étant le parfait exemple mais
l'archéologie dans ce marketing
audiovisuel et a pas simplement parce
que c'est une science ou vendre
l'archéologie comme on vendrait un film
d'action
ça pose problème alors comment raconter
l'histoire sans raconter des histoires
des histoires édulcorée au
catastrophique
eh bien ce n'est pas toujours évident
pour chaque vidéo j'essaye de faire
quelque chose qui me plaît tout en
pensant à vous qui la regarderai en
espérant que ça nous sera utile
un peu comme un cadeau il m'arrive
souvent douté avant la publication d'un
épisode persuadé que ce ne sera pas
assez alléchant et heureusement vous est
au rendez vous et vos commentaires
m'encouragent chaque fois à recommencer
alors merci merci d'être là de regarder
d'écrire de partage et de liker de typé
et par là de faire vivre la chaîne
j'espère que ce contenu vous inspire
vous fait voyager quelques instants et
vous donne envie d'apprendre d'une autre
manière
je vous souhaite à toutes et à tous une
très belle année 2010 8
[Musique]